there's been a domino effect in the
collapse of the crypto industry
the fall of the stablecoin Tara sparked
a wave of losses leading to bankruptcy
filings for five major crypto companies
paused withdrawals and declining value
for cryptocurrencies but the contagion
effects to the wider economy have been
limited so there's like massive Carnage
over here but not much impact over here
usually when an industry collapses
it has the potential to Ripple far out
to other parts of the economy and can
even spark a financial crisis but so far
for crypto the Fallout has been pretty
contained here's why the crypto
Industries collapse has happened in a
closed loop
[Music]
the finances of many crypto companies
are intertwined it's a very incestuous
kind of scene where you have the same
companies lending to each other
borrowing from each other and then
trading with each other just looking at
a slice of the industry you can see how
closely related those five bankrupt
companies were three arrows a crypto
focused hedge fund had invested in
crypto assets and companies and took
loans out from other companies one of
these Investments was Tara's sister
token Luna when these assets fell so did
three arrows is balance sheet as a
result the company failed to repay debts
and was ordered to liquidate in June in
the wake of that bankruptcy crypto
lenders block fi Voyager and Celsius
were taking losses on declining digital
currency prices and on loans they had
given to three arrows then crypto
exchange FTX extended a line of credit
to block Phi and its sister company
Alameda extended a line to Voyager
Voyager filed for bankruptcy in July a
few days later Celsius did too and when
FTX filed for bankruptcy in November due
to a mismanagement of funds blockfi
followed it's like these companies are
all wearing these different hats with
each other so you can see how these
companies are so interconnected and so
intermingled that it sets the stage for
contagion to have a really devastating
effect the financial stability oversight
Council set in a report in October that
this interconnectedness is part of why
the industry can crumble so quickly
one of the reasons those companies are
so tightly linked traditional Finance
institutions have stayed pretty
separated from crypto for example if you
look at the list of some of celsius's
biggest creditors in their bankruptcy
filing there aren't any banks listed in
other Industries for example banks will
provide credit lines or arrange
corporate bonds or do other sorts of
financings in crypto it's been much more
limited there just hasn't been the same
Embrace that other Industries have seen
as small handful of banks like these
have corded crypto companies but big
players in the financial Market have
been more hesitant okay I'm a major
skeptic on crypto tokens which you call
currency like Bitcoin regulation for
banks which is help set by the office of
the Comptroller of the currency requires
them to have a number of safety measures
in place before engaging with digital
assets the resilience of the traditional
banking system to the recent events in
crypto is not an accident rather it is
due at least in part to Federal Bank
Regulators continued an intentional
emphasis on safety and soundness and
consumer protection crypto makes up just
0.01 percent of exposure for banks since
the traditional Wall Street banks have
not really participated in this space
it's been left to the crypto companies
themselves to act as like de facto Banks
within the space you see how these
companies have become so interconnected
and intermingled that the failure of one
can bring down the rest
but that isolation has helped prevent
the crypto crisis from spilling into the
larger economy think about the housing
crash in 2007 that eventually led to the
Great Recession when housing prices
declined it sparked a crisis in subprime
loans as some banks had a stake in these
type of mortgages that crisis leaked
into the traditional Financial system it
began to snowball and cause the
system-wide Meltdown and major financial
institutions like Lehman Brothers failed
because of their exposure to the housing
market other Industries like housing
also have value in the economy there's
dollars behind it but crypto's value is
still mostly speculative this is what
happens when you have a lot of money
pouring into an unregulated industry
that has little discernible clear value
aside from the speculation itself well
the crash has been mostly contained in
this case it's left a lot of questions
about how financial institutions might
interact with the industry in the future